[Music]
you just click down a thumbnail that
promised you photos of pineapple boobs
and we're gonna get there and promise
and then after that we're also going to
talk about a new documentary about
dating apps and heck we're even gonna
talk about the Mars rover taking a
selfie but first those pineapple boobs
that you were promised so according to
vice panicle boobs are a thing on
Instagram right now show that photo
Gillian how it works is that you take a
topless photograph of yourself and put
some pineapples in front of your breasts
like everything on the internet people
are already doing variations of it show
that next slide Oh
hashtag pineapple moves family just like
his body what do we think of this trend
anyone gonna participate Jordan as an
a-cup I would love you know I think
pineapples would help me out so we got
one yes uh-huh
anybody else I'll do it sure I mean I
think this is clearly a protest against
instagrams puritanical and sexist nudity
laws that allow men like myself to show
my breasts but women like you guys
cannot show yours I think that's it I
think it's that Kim Kardashian talked
about pineapple juice making it smell
and taste delicious now women are using
the pineapples to be like look at this
body this is fresh
[Laughter]
[Applause]
something else that I find exhausting is
online dating and keeping up with it so
put up that headlines cuz you're married
even just knowing that people are still
online dating exhaust me HBO called
swiped hooking up in the digital age and
guess what folks
it takes a dark look at online dating it
looks at things like objectification and
how these apps were intentionally
designed to get you addicted to swiping
what do we think online dating a net
good or net ilford society it is
addicting I find it so fun you just what
I've done it I've done a lot and like I
have a girlfriend now but yesterday I
was watching TV and I was like man I
wish I could swipe right now not - I
feel like oh man I feel like a God of
like no no no like denying people it
feels it feels fun are you mostly a
swipe left okay uh no men arms what you
men accept clarified because that's not
really my experience I'm nothing you've
gotta believe this yeah I just I just
deleted hinge because it's the one where
they recommend people for you they're
like we think you and Connor would be
great and it's like a twenty
eight-year-old skateboarder who like
doesn't live in a house and I'm like I'd
be more like oh yeah guys aren't on it
really but I have not gotten it's just
it's upsetting and I'm it's it it's
supposed to like make you feel better
but my self-esteem is for sure gone yeah
but you primarily use these apps to
invite men to come to your to your
comedy shows right yeah and I have a
show on Saturday and know each other
online dating no no I knew there from
comedy mmm yeah just real life whatever
happen just walk outside go outside with
no intentions on doing anything that's
what you used to do back with it you
will go outside like what are you going
outside yeah Ryan met his girlfriend in
a park outside right that's good I mean
I mean I I mean you go to your grand
plans will jump outside meet outside no
one means no one meets indoors oh if you
do me to do it's weird I don't think
it's that bad I think online dating is
good yeah things like is it a good net
good or net bad it's like if human
beings are involved it's it's right in
the middle for the most part yeah it's
just a very human thing some people are
monsters some people get married up
those things so it's like I think it's
fine and it's and for like some people
are very weird when they're outside all
right so I think Ryan might have a good
point that whenever humans are involved
it's gonna be a little bad and a little
good which is why I'm so excited about
this next story
robots NASA's Curiosity Mars rover
imitated humans show that next photo on
mars took a little selfie because it's
using a circular camera that took a 360
view and this is the selfie part of that
that's why it looks stretched out and
weird it's the size of a bride it's a
beautiful that's right it's a panoramic
image of the Vera Rubin Ridge on the Red
Planet
yes but Ryan by calling it a selfie
don't you think that then it's more
likely that people will click on that
headline and then people like us will
talk about it on our internet show yeah
because science needs to just grease the
wheels because everybody out here she's
talking about clicks to appreciate them
Spacey but hots us to 80s now look back
in 10 day and a day B was to get dressed
up to care about the launch you know
she's doing Mars some kids I have my own
spaceship I don't give a crap yeah
hopefully you don't give a about
Mars and that's why you're not gonna get
your own I want to go outside and beyond
I would have beat some Mars ladies maybe
that could help dating problem would you
bother why would you not go out with it
no first of all I don't know who they
are so I gotta get to know him first if
I wasn't married I would say I'm
definitely dating in Mars
that's very I'm very open-minded about
my Marty dad - probably too small of
tongues Tom would you date someone on my
if you was not taken would you go for
Mars date I you saying that reminded me
when I saw fit element I think I want to
like yeah date someone who's an alien I
remember watching movies like I'm very
attracted to a lot of the aliens on this
planet there's like human flesh light
and then they just have Navi from what's
that movie the James Cameron movie
Avatar avatar I do not know that unless
like you go on the website and there's
just a human option and there's a flex
lights not just for solo people yeah
your parents can use it if tightly
spice things up or maybe yeah like when
your parents use it like leave us a
comment for us I got a shout out this
from Ryan Barrett
thank you for that flashlight
okay I have a shout-out from John B and
a week ago we did a segment and Jordan
said a joke about comedy senshu and miss
marvel it looks great it's just it's
weird that Marvel has a movie called
Captain Marvel that's like if Tommy
central had a show called Captain
Marvel's it's weird that Marvel comic
called Captain Marvel what would that be
like in Comedy Central had a show called
Captain Marvel it's so weird that Marvel
has a movie called because that would be
like if Comedy Central had a show called
Captain Marvel okay and Jon be said
Jordan's joke was epic sounds like it
means it means it it was if you want to
know do you want to restate their jokes
Wow okay weird that Marvel has welcome
back to another rousing edition of color
commentary where we'll be breaking down
a doozy of an internet video here today
I'm Ryan back and as always I'm joined
by my partner in crime Chris cotton and
for the record I have no recollection of
being a partner in any crime in which
Ryan is referring to just a crime of
passion of watching a ridiculous
internet video
this is the Holy Spirit fire conference
and whoa boom he opens with a moonwalk
straight into a healing
he's a flashy dresser in a limbo fella I
hope he plays tennis with a backhand
that impressive in the current climate
of sexual harassment I salute him for
using hands-off healing techniques
detail in black white male female bring
your pets he'll let the dogs loose his
healing would be nothing without his
impeccable healed receivers let's take a
look at this catch this woman appeared
to be a simple catch than booth another
dose here you see the importance of
keeping your eyes on the hill till you
get that healing will take us into half
time Wow Chris halfway through that
video and I cannot wait to see what
happens next
IV in so many nachos I don't know how
I'm gonna make it through the second
half right out of halftime booth he
comes back with a beautiful display of
spirit dude try saying that three times
fast
you're sure didn't Chris what are the
odds that some of these people are
acting high very high as my father would
say he couldn't cast a fly out of a
policy what was that did he just
spiritually decapitate his own healed
receivers somebody called the coroner
according to his jewellery microphone
and jacket somebody's getting a little
handsy with the collection fleet who
knows how much all this photo shop costs
wow what a video we've truly sees
something special here today and by that
I mean what you did to those nachos
those nachos would straight through me
let's wrap it up thanks for joining us
on another color commentary
if today someone came and from NASA and
said you can go to Mars you're gonna
live there for five years you won't talk
to your friends and family would you do
it that's not how that works they don't
send you for five years they send you
for ever
yeah that's oh my god my hypothetical
question you know the scenario would you
do this
yes or no god I answer your question No
[Laughter]
[Music]